you know we used to carry pornographic
magazines mainly to show to the Soviet
soldiers when we want to get them into
conversation so that was that something
they didn't have oh no definitely not
all right so you know to give a to give
a Soviet Soldier when you bumped into
them on the road or something like that
you know even let them have a look at
one and you know if we took it back of
them or let them have it for a bit of
information as to God that's so
unbelievable isn't it
[Music]
thank you
so Dave we've met before obviously but
what I'm going to do for New listeners
or viewers is just ask if you could give
a brief introduction to yourself
yeah so my name's uh Dave Butler and uh
I'm former British Army
and uh I spent three years uh in
bricsmas the British
commander-in-chief's mission to a group
of Soviet forces Germany which were uh
from 1986 to 1989 working out of Berlin
uh behind the Iron Curtain as it was
then so when you say brixmus can you
explain for people who might not be
clear on what that is what it was yeah
this was um a mission that was set up at
the end of the second World War uh by
the Soviets and the Allies the Americans
the French and ourselves the British in
the divided Germany and they decided to
split Germany up into four SEC segments
and um there was an agreement made
called the Robertson Molina agreement
which meant that each Ally was allowed
to have a liaison Mission which could
run for freely in each other's territory
or
divide at that time and the idea was the
over side was that it was a liaison
Mission so our job was to liaise with
the Soviet troops
and and the on and to keep an eye on
each other was really the the underlying
message to make sure that there were no
unnecessary buildups of forces in in
each other's areas
okay great so what I'd love to do to
start with is go right back to the start
and for a lot of our listeners or
viewers they'll have a vague
understanding of you know Germany and
the situation of the second world war
but I'd love it if you could just talk
through as simply as possible
what was the situation in Germany at the
end of the war as in how is it divided
up how would it got there well of course
Germany was defeated and
um mainly or not mainly but in part due
to the Russians the Americans the French
and ourselves so we were the occupying
forces at that time and and so it was
decided that um that forces would remain
in Germany and each would have a segment
of Germany so as an example the British
we got the northern half of of Germany
uh the Americans got got the southern
half
um and the majority of the eastern half
was occupied by Soviet troops
um and in particular and that even went
as far as Berlin where it was decided
that that each Allied force would have
um a mission in in Berlin and sorry
Berlin itself was divided into four
segments with the Soviets the British
the Americans and the French wow so you
had the whole country divided then you
had Berlin divided even further exactly
wow okay so
essentially what happened is the Allies
had won the second world war together
and then we divided up Germany
why was there a need to divide it up if
we were essentially on the same side
during that period of time
I I think and this is just a guess that
um the the Soviets in particular were
very keen not to give up any ground that
they had made and and of course bearing
in mind they lost a million men just
taking Berlin itself so the Soviets in
particular had a had a great desire not
to give up an inch of that ground that
they had captured and I think as a sort
of a quid pro quo we also of course the
Allies the Western allies had also lost
you know large numbers of of men uh
taking that ground and so I think we
were probably not as Keen as as the
Soviets but but in order to maintain the
status quo we also decided to stay where
we were
and do you think that at that point in
time the relationship between the uh you
know the Soviets and the UK and America
was it was a good one or do you think
there was already immediate frictions
appearing I think I think as soon as the
war ended
um it was made quite clear
by the Soviets that they wanted to
increase their territory
um and I think we in the west were under
No Illusion that um if we pulled out of
Germany the Soviets would occupy the
whole of the the whole of Germany and so
I think
I think yes I think relationships broke
down quite soon afterwards is it fair to
say that during your period of service
you acted as a spy is that an okay title
for me to use
I think I think
um to the Layman yes I mean we we are
intelligence gatherers and I guess it
depends on your definition of of what
intelligence gathering actually entails
you know and so it it normally you know
my view is that that we were there
gathering information uh both uh
photographically and physically wherever
we could
um and without being without being
caught and so I think you know if you if
you think about what spiers do the other
sorts of spies you James Bonds and that
you know they spent a lot of time
Gathering it's all about Gathering the
intelligence and so I guess I guess yes
you could use that
that term great I just don't want to
throw it about if you're uncomfortable
with it but I understand what you're
saying that it's it's kind of a probably
a simplification but a one that people
would understand I I think it I think it
helps to make the definition between the
liaison role that we had the overt one
and the intelligence gathering one you
know
um to make that sort of differential
well let's go through that then so you
had two roles as you said at the
beginning you had the liaison role and
you had the intelligence coloring role
which was more of a
unofficial and probably not outwardly
announced role what what did the liaison
role entail like officially what was it
okay so one of the best examples I could
give you is that we had a we had a
little office within our organization
called Spandau
okay and Spandau were a group of Russian
speakers interpreters military British
Military and when Rudolf Hess was
incarcerated in in Spandau prison
the the Soviets insisted that on a
rotational basis each of the Allies
would be responsible for looking after
Rudolf Hess this was just another one of
those Soviet rules is to to get an
excuse to come into our part of Berlin
because it was in the British sector
Spandau was in our sector and so when
that happened when the Soviets were in
charge of Rudolf Hess our Spandau office
did all the interpreting between
officials that went to see Rudolf
Harrison and between the Soviets and and
him because they could speak German as
well out our interpreters so that was a
good example of the over liaison role
that that we and brixmus did and the
over liaison role
the pretense of it was that it was
helping relations I suppose it was
communicating together and and breaching
the gap between the different areas yeah
exactly and I mean and again uh we used
to do a thing called Town tours as well
um and like away days is what I would
probably the modern day term for it
where I would take my family uh in a
mini bus
um it was basically a crew of us but
with our families and we would we would
go to somewhere like Dresden and we
would stay in a hotel in Dresden and um
basically show the flag because we were
all wearing British military uniform
with Union Jacks everywhere and and the
idea was to portray to the General
Public
what it was like to be somebody from the
west and we would engage civilians in
conversations and they would ask us who
we were and what we did and we would
tell them so another form of like
liaison and I was giving a budget to go
out there and and do that for instance
we were going to an ice cream parlor and
buy all the kids there and ice cream you
know because that's apparently what we
do in the west I see so uh part of it
was raising the profile of what life was
like in the West in that it was sort of
luxurious like all our kids get ice
cream all the time and that's what
that's what happens over with us yeah so
I think I think you have to bear in mind
that that times in in East Germany were
were quite hard
um for the whole of the time that the
Soviets occupied it I mean they they
punished the East Germans in my view
for the amount of people they lost until
that end they didn't do any renovation I
mean during my time there you could go
to Dresden it was like the day after the
Thousand bomber raid I mean they did no
rebuilding and the general public were
kept you know on low pay and um and good
old communist way of you know everybody
did
one thing or the other and so times were
not were quite hard for for your average
East German so the idea was that you'd
show up there in the sort of British
military uniform
portraying this kind of opulent
lifestyle where you'd be buying the kids
ice creams having a nice car going on
holidays to that area or something like
that and but what was the end goal of
that was it just to show look we're
doing better than you or was there an
intention to kind of make people come
across or what why why would that be uh
something that the Army would want to do
is it is it just propaganda just we're
doing better we've got more money I I
think actually exactly that I think it
was more you know propaganda
psychological warfare if you like
um you know did it contribute to to the
final falling of the of the inner German
border and the you know the war coming
down
we'll never know
I suspect our role in it was pretty
small in that respect but you know every
little bit helps and uh you know I think
it was just trying to make because they
were fed all the time that we were the
the bad guys on the other side of the
Iron Curtain and we were going to attack
them at any moment in time right so it's
presenting a kind of friendly family
face
making it seem like the propaganda on
their side wasn't necessarily accurate
yeah and and it's interesting that since
reunification you know I've now got a
couple of friends one was an East German
army colonel and the other one was um uh
was a a Soviet
um Gru officer and it's interesting the
conversations we've had since
reunification about you know when I said
to them that we were told at any moment
they were going to start rolling West
and attackers and they said well that's
interesting Dave because we were told
exactly the same about you
so you have to you have to ask yourself
who was indoctrinating who that's
interesting and when you so you were
sort of the liaison officers that were
allowed passage into their side and you
and you did your bits if you as you've
been describing there was so the flip of
that was was the people from their side
that would come into the British areas
and and the American areas and would
they do the same thing like buying kids
ice creams and stuff or what was their
version of that yeah I mean the Russian
liaison team was called socksmiths uh so
you were brick Smith and they were
socksmiths exactly and their
headquarters in the British sector was
in Bunda uh and again they had a similar
quantity of personal because each
country was allocated a certain number
of people who were allowed to to run
freely as as liaison officers so in our
sector I mean we had I think 31 of us
that were allowed to roam in East
Germany and I think socksmiths had a
similar number that were allowed to be
again and you know we our intelligence
Services spent some time trying to find
out what socks and this were doing in
and around West Germany
um I think our major feeling was that
they they were more interested in in uh
industrial targets and stuff like that
so that if they ever did come West you
know uh it was more about
what they would do to destabilize Us in
those early days of of conflict
so there's an interesting thing going on
there isn't it where you're both
allowing
both sides are allowing the other side
to enter their areas as a kind of
gesture of Goodwill and keeping contact
but both sides are aware that the other
side is doing it to basically get the
data and spy on each other really yeah
as I've said after you know they knew
what we were doing and we knew that they
knew what we were doing but it was just
that that fine line that you had to you
had to tread you know
um saying and it was just like um you
know an acceptance that uh you know
you're allowed to do
what you what you could and um and we
did as much as we could without them
knowing
um which has since been confirmed that
there was a lot of what we did you know
from just talking to my former adverses
that they they really in some instances
had no idea right what we were up to so
that that was good confirmation for us
we were doing the job well yeah well
okay let's get on to that a little bit
so we've got these I'm just going to
keep repeating it for the listeners so
it kind of paints a portrait but so
we've got this Germany that's been
divided into four areas and then you've
got Berlin within Germany divided into
four areas and you've got the Allies
moving into the uh Soviets area and the
Soviets moving into the Allies areas and
the overt mission is kind of
peacekeeping saying hello staying in
touch and then the covert mission
let's get on to that what was your sort
of covert Mission yeah so the cover side
was to uh get photographic evidence
um of all of the troops that were in
East Germany uh where the units were who
the units were what their makeup was
what equipment they had bearing in mind
that at that time in the three years I
was there from 86 to 89 there were 186
000
Soviet troops stationed in East Germany
God and 240 000 East German troops so
you know getting on half a million men
and women underarms with all the
associated equipment so I mean for us it
meant that wherever you went there
wasn't a day went by when you didn't
turn a corner and bump into something
that was either moving on the roads or
on the railways or through the air and
so you know
for us it was it was you know a real
uh honey pot to to tap into and um
so photographically it was it was was
one of the objectives and and secondly
was to
um try to get hold of
any equipment that they left lying
around
um you know physical military equipment
and also of course there was the um the
operation Tomahawk which was the the
classified
Scavenging of all of their rubbish dumps
which uh
which I had many of and many of them
right next to their barracks and so I
mean this was a real classified
operation at the time and we used to
spend hours in the dead of night
um on those rubbish dumps with different
devices and that looking for evidence of
of paper evidence of what they were up
to but would they I mean was it
effective were they throwing were they
throwing vital evidence into the trash
interesting enough Yes yes again you
know one man's rubbish is another man's
guy sure you know and so you know uh I
mean one interesting fact was that that
for reasons known only for themselves
they they never really got issued toilet
paper so they would they would wipe
their bums and that on on documents or
tear Pages out of their notebooks or
whatever and then throw them up letters
from home in particular
um anything to get their hands on and
then discard it whether it was on a
rubbish dump or in their deployment
areas and so we would systematically
scoop all that up and and it was worth
its weight in gold in fact the
intelligence Services told us that if
the mission did nothing else but bring
back the tomahawk
um stuff it was worth keeping us in in
place so ultimately you were going to
these rubbish dumps and you were finding
what was essentially toilet paper but
they were they were wiping themselves on
sensitive information
correct yeah apparently not just not
just what they wipe their bums on for
again they used to throw enormous amount
the thing with the Soviets was and
because back in the 80s you know we
didn't have uh digital staff and the
rest of it so everything had to be drawn
or or
um diagrams of of bits and pieces uh I
mean an example was one of my colleagues
one night there was a new tank came into
into East Germany called the t80 tank
and so it was a High collection priority
for the intelligence services and um and
one of my colleagues found all these
diagrams that have been thrown onto this
over the Barrett wall which had all of
the inside of the tank laid out all the
firing mechanisms the auto loader
mechanism it was just it was just you
know pure gold and someone had just not
even ripped it up
thankfully they hadn't but if they had
it on we'd appears to all together sure
wow I mean that's so operation Tomahawk
the Scavenging of the rubbish dumps do
you think the there was a similar thing
going on on your side or do you think
that was something that was just
happening to them not to my knowledge
um not to my knowledge and and again
this was one of the questions I have for
this former Gru officer friend of mine
you know about if they knew about that
and I mean he told me that they didn't
um but then I understand in another
interview that he did
um he said oh yes we we knew about that
um but they just thought it was
insignificant
um I don't think they realized just the
information they were giving away you
know and um and the same for us for our
intelligence agencies it was absolute
Gold Dust you know it's So when you say
the rubbish dumps are you talking about
kind of like a couple of bags of rubbish
out the back like what does that look
like did you turn up in the dead of
night and sneak into the into the tape
or well I guess most people don't have a
much of an idea what a municipal rubbish
thumb looks like but I mean you know
this could be like a 40 or 50 foot high
wall of rubbish where uh where P where
dumper trucks similar to what we have in
the UK that collect your rubbish every
would just drive back onto it and then
offload it onto I remember one night I
was buried in the rubbish and and a
Truck came onto the site and it was as
much as I could do to get out the way
before about 50 tons of of new rubbish
which of course contained everything
from you know food waste toilet waste
everything I mean it was just you know
and that smell has never left me every
time I I drive past a rubbish dump in
the UK and that smell I have a flashback
to those good old days and I I actually
found it very
um you know very interesting to do that
sort of thing it was a sort of rats you
know that kind of thing yeah we had
night vision goggles mvgs as we call
them in the military uh which just
create a very small uh beam of light and
also of course pick up ambient light and
I remember turning on one night and just
looking around a rubbish dump and it was
absolutely alive with with rats and wild
dogs I mean everything was on there
Scavenging you know depend what you were
Scavenging for you know and um and so
yeah that was a bit unnerving because
again you know there's always the rabies
threat and stuff like that the left-hand
be out of James Bond didn't they the
rats in the rubbish thing yeah yeah I
wouldn't have been doing it in my tuxedo
and what what was the kind of when you
said there about a sort of dumper truck
appearing like what was the Threat Level
to you like if you'd been caught doing
that yeah it was it was High I mean and
you know we were it was made absolutely
clear to us that on no account
must we be caught because that would
have been you know our chief of mission
who was a one-star Brigadier would have
had difficulty explaining that away and
certainly in my three years and I'm
pretty certain within the whole of brics
Miss history nobody was ever caught on a
on a rugby stump and we only did it
between about two and four o'clock in
the morning so in the dead of night when
there was only us and the rats and the
dogs you know around although again I
was on one rubbish stunt one night and
there were there were civilians
um Scavenging as well right you know
which I think was sort of a would would
shed some light on on you know
the levels of poverty right in East
Germany you know I mean the poor were
very poor and you know considered in
communism is supposed to be everybody's
equal clearly some are more equal than
others yeah sure okay
that's interesting so operation Tomahawk
there was the kind of as you said the
systematic Scavenging of rubbish dumps
um when you say that the danger level
was high if you've been caught do you
think there would have been a threat to
life or would it be more imprisonment or
more more returned with your tail
between your legs and then in trouble
from your superiors well I think I think
uh the reality was that of course like I
said a lot of the dumps were at the back
of Barracks where there were guard
towers with guards with live ammunition
so I think their first response had they
have heard us or seen us would have been
to shoot so I think the uh the threat
there was was quite high of being
discovered
um the other threat really was was
getting on and off them
um and I did take an awful tumble one
night
um down about 40 50 foot Bank in the
dark but luckily of course you couldn't
scream or cry out
um yeah my left leg just gave way and I
and I went and there were two of us me
and the uh and the tour officer on the
dump and of course we couldn't talk to
each other
and but luckily I kept holding my sack
which had all the rubbish and I'd
collected I wasn't going to let go of
that and I ended up at the bottom and um
subsequently had a knee operation on my
left leg oh wow so it's quite a serious
oh yeah yeah okay and then how about
some of the more
potentially what the general public
could see as more kind of traditional
spyops like retrieving objects or
military ammunition or kit that kind of
thing yeah again it was it was
absolutely an sop of as a stand
operational procedure that um if we saw
say live firing or something going on on
a range as soon as the Soviets pulled
back off the range at the end of the day
we would go on there and scavenge for
anything
um you know the the letters I've just
described that the Soviets would read
and then throw out the vehicles through
to ammunition for some Curious reason if
a piece of ammunition didn't work
properly they would just throw it out
the vehicle and then leave it behind
well that was our interpretation that we
left it behind whether whether they
intended to come and collect it
afterwards because in between we would
get on there and um so we would find all
sorts of fin stabilized ammunition I
mean it was it was an absolute gold mine
for us and of course
um because of our skill bases we knew
that that the ammunition wasn't
necessarily live ammunition they were
firing uh I had live Warheads
um so we would we would pick those sort
of things up
um and uh and and put them in the
vehicles and then bring them back to
Berlin to our headquarters where they
would then be looked at by analysts and
decided what to do with them and when
you're driving those pieces of
ammunition or you know materials back to
Berlin was a never worry of getting
stopped at any check posts or anything
like that or was it because of who you
were you were allowed free passage yeah
the vehicles were actually like a mini
sort of Embassy on Wheels if you like so
the Soviets were not allowed to
um you know enter the vehicles although
if you were if you were caught then they
would always try the doors but we kept
the doors locked at all times
um one one ruse they had of course was
they would Ram the vehicle and knock it
over
um and then and then say that was an
accident and then on the pretext of
saving the crew they would then
pay no attention to us but get their
hands on all of our photographic
equipment and any other bits and pieces
we had in the vehicle and then this
would all be presented to our chief of
mission in Potsdam at the Soviet
external relations branch which were the
organization that were responsible for
looking after military missions they
would lay all this out and then say you
know you've been spying because we had a
a really good array of Nikon cameras
with all sorts of lenses and our chief
remission would sit there straight faced
and say that that actually no
Ornithology was one of the missions big
um big things and and therefore these
were purely the binoculars and
everything cameras were for bird
watching ah again what sounds so bizarre
to me is someone completely outside it
is like that's obviously not true
but
was that just the game that everyone was
playing yeah as you say you know they
knew what we were doing we knew they
knew what we were doing and there was a
there was a line that that you know
it shouldn't be crossed since
reunification and
the investigating the starsy
headquarters in East Berlin of course we
found all of our records and so we were
able to apply for our starsy file and uh
I did and I got mine
um I have to say it was heavily redacted
but but the bits that were in there
um
indicate that apparently
Dave Butler was only interested in ice
creams and um and pornographic magazines
which I sort of found interesting oh and
spending large amounts of of East German
coin
so did that give you a bit of
um were you kind of relaxed to hear that
they didn't have too much on you or was
that kind of surprising that they didn't
know as much as they might have I I
think I think it was there was a couple
of surprising things uh I mean you know
we used to carry pornographic magazines
mainly to show to the Soviet soldiers
when we want to get them into
conversation so that was that something
they didn't have oh no definitely not
all right and so you know to give her to
give a Soviet Soldier when you bumped
into them on the road or something like
that you know even let them have a look
at one and you know if we took it back
of them or let them have it for a bit of
information as to
sort of unbelievable isn't it
um okay but the fact the fact that they
knew that we had these meant that that
they were using long range
um uh binoculars and photographic that
they were photographing Us in the
vehicles
um and and also listening to our
conversations whenever they could get
near enough to the to the vehicles did
you suspect that at the time that they
were spying on you that closely well we
were Yes actually we were informed I
think that well again we used to be
guarded at all times where we had
conversations I mean uh we used to go
outside at our mission house in Potsdam
which which was adjaced to a large lake
and there was a building across the lake
and it was only after reunification we
found out that they had a long-range
listening device in this building across
the lake
um to try to pick up our conversations
because we always assume that our
mission house was bugged we knew that
all the staff there were working for the
stazi and had to report everything we
did and so we would go outside if we
wanted to talk about anything
sensitively and so it sort of told us
the lengths that the Soviets went to to
try to find out exactly what we were
doing and what we were up to and let's
talk about some of the other points
during your time there where you sort of
retrieved interesting or sensitive
materials or equipment I think I
remember talking when we talked before
you told me a story about sneaking up on
a sleeping officer and stealing his
backpack something like that can you go
through that story yeah yes again you
know we're always very interested in the
Soviet Soldier because you know in real
terms over our our potential adversary
so we used to want to know everything we
could about them and a lot of
information about that came from the op
Tomahawk where we would read their
letters from home and find out how
disgruntle they were that half of them
didn't know they were actually in East
Germany
um and and all sorts of things but on
the other on the other side of the coin
um yeah again what What They Carried was
interesting and um so one day I just had
the opportunity
um we were going through a wooded area
and and the Soviets were there and one
of them was a nice sunny day and one who
was asleep by a tree so the Mercedes
Glenda wagon being automatic was very
good at being able to go in low gear and
sneak up without them hearing so we got
to within sort of walking distance and
I'm made the decision to to climb out
and and go up and I just picked up his
rucksack and got back in the vehicle and
we and we left him sleeping
um I did feel sorry for the gun for
about a second right and anyway when we
got back we then uh analyzed what it was
and almost all of the equipment in there
was to do with nuclear biological and
chemical was his protective suit and all
rest of it and the only other thing that
was in there was a knife Fork and Spoon
and a bowl
um and so it was it no sleeping bags
um and so that sort of confirmed a few
things to us that one you know your
average Soviet Soldier is a pretty hardy
hardy Beast
um they never had sleeping bags
um they never had socks they would just
wrap their feet in in like
um like a towel in thing and then stuff
the boot on and I mean sometimes I mean
in East Germany in the winter it would
get to minus 25. yeah and there was me
in my arctic sleeping bag and my my
adversary was out there sleeping just in
a year to tent with a fire going in the
middle of it with no sleeping bags at
all is that do you think because they
couldn't afford it or because they just
thought they didn't need it
I I think maybe it was it was a bit of
both I think um as I say my impression
always was and still is that as I say
your average side of it on our Russian
soldier is is pretty used to hardship
and I think that was part of their
military training was it was to keep
them you know as hard as possible by
depriving them you know in a sense of of
some of the niceties in life which just
made them you know all the more Hardy
quite did that make them quite an
intimidating enemy uh I think I think uh
yes it did
um and of course would mean that and the
other thing I found for from a good
example was they will always obey the
last order
um obviously tane once and I have to
have the chief of our mission in the
back of the vehicle because he liked to
go out touring so that he knew what we
were doing and we got detained they
covered the vehicle in the tire pulling
and um it was August a bit like the
temperatures today about 30 degrees and
they kept the rear so the temperature
inside the vehicle I managed to get out
of it and shut the door and lock it so I
was on the outside and and I said in my
in my pigeon German to the to the
Soviets that had detained us you know
basically I started to sort of chastise
them in German and tell them that I had
the chief of the British military
mission on here and and they would be
for the high jump when their commandant
turned up and found that they treated us
in this way
um and anyway at the end of the day so
there was an armed Soldier behind me by
the door and then uh the commandantura
who was probably a half Colonel
um in the Soviet Army turned up
and said to this uh conscript who was
stood by me with it with his gun to take
the tarpaulin off the vehicle
and he flatly refused
um but anyway this guy was like a
private and this was a half kernel and
he flatly refused to do it and the only
person he would he would do it for was
the lieutenant in his unit who'd come up
and told him to put the tarpaulin on and
we had to wait for the left tenant to
turn up and tell him to take it off
before he would actually remove the
tarpaulin my God
so they were a rigid obedience to the
rules and and that's and that's exactly
how how the Russians or the Soviets were
and still are you know they do
everything by numbers you know they do
this they do that which of course takes
away a lot of what we in the British
army had was the ability to think on our
feet and and you know manage the
situation as it happened they didn't
they would just obey the last order you
know which which again was a Telltale
for us you know what they're like okay
we're gonna take a quick break now to
talk about this episode's sponsor uh and
it is in fact manscaped uh we received a
great package from manscape to try out
and I thought I'd pass it on someone who
might make better use of it than me so
this is Conor one of our producers how
did you find it Connor yeah very very
good we were sent the performance
package 4.0 which included the lawnmower
4.0 one of the recommended trimmers and
I can say I would recommend it too
definitely great best thing for me Ben
is it's waterproof so you can use it in
the shower so it saves time when you're
having a wash in the morning you can get
your Trim in there
um it included the premium body wash as
well which smells great what's it smell
like aloe vera and sea salt lovely very
very nice indeed and but my favorite
part of it I have to say is the
anti-chafe boxer shorts which uh yeah a
great little number do what they're
saying that's in very very smooth and uh
yeah I would recommend so it's a glowing
review from collar there and if you want
to think about getting it for yourself
or for someone else with Christmas
coming up extraordinary lives listeners
get free shipping and 20 off go to
manscape.com and use the code minutes at
the checkout that's 20 off with the free
shipping at manscape.com just use the
code minutes I'm sure you told me a
story before about
camera Kodak camera or something like
that being chased with it and throwing
it into the woods or something was there
something like that
yeah another another uh incident was
again
yeah we were always tasked with
intelligence gathering tasks and one of
them was to go and try to photograph and
video if we could
um a specialist piece of sovere
equipment which I used to call IPR it
was actually called irm but I called it
IPR this vehicle Soviet equipment
vehicle was it used to probe the
riverbed so the Soviet tanks could all
snorkel across Rivers okay and so this
vehicle would go ahead of them and it
would drive into the off the riverbank
along the riverbed to make sure it was
firm enough and then come out the other
side and I used to call it IPR because
it stood for ipro Rivers okay or
riverbeds yeah but its actual
designation was irm so this was a High
collection priority to get as much uh
photographic evidence of it so we knew
where it was operating on a driver
training so Market
down near a place called elster galin
which was uh on the side of a riverbank
where they used to do Soviet River
Crossings
so we went down there and we parked the
vehicle up in the woods uh and me and
the tour officer got out this was in
November the snow was deep on the ground
and we took I took my little dictaphone
to uh to record what I saw and and
anything else and the tour officer had a
couple of Nikon cameras with different
lenses attached to them and so we
sneaked off about 100 meters from the
vehicle to the edge of this on a corner
because we could hear the vehicle
driving around the woods and lo and
behold it came along and so we started
to take some pictures of it and the rest
of it we knew that the starsy the secret
police knew that we were in the area
and so what we didn't know was they had
alerted the Soviet troops that there was
a a mission vehicle in the area so they
were all on sort of high alert and um
and I don't know what it is about people
on vehicles moving vehicles I don't know
if you've ever looked at them but if you
look at somebody for some reason only
known to them they always turn and look
at you and so there we were hiding in
the bushes on this corner and as this
IPR vehicle went past us the commander
for some reason known only to him
turned his head and looked back at us or
looked back in our Direction
we weren't sure if he'd seen us or not
but anyway the vehicle continued on the
next minute uh a Russian Jeep a was 469
came hurtling along the track where this
vehicle had been
um turned in front of us and saw our
vehicle which was parked about 100
meters from us and started to hurdle
towards our vehicle our driver
knowing knowing that where we were and
that we couldn't get back to the vehicle
in time he immediately reversed at high
reverse and did a j turn at the end of
the woods and led the Soviets away from
us okay and rushed off into the town
being chased by them
so we waited uh half expecting him we
heard a gunshot being fired as well so
we knew that they shot the vehicle as
well anyway we waited for
about an hour
um expecting at any minute Soviet troops
would be coming through the woods
combingham to find us so we took the
film out the cameras because in those
days of course it was all rolls of film
it wasn't Digital Light nowadays
um put the film in our Underpants which
which of course was the place where
mostly you weren't searched and buried
the cameras in the wood again made a
note of where it was
um and uh and took some pictures on the
camera before we buried them and where
we were going to bury them and my
dictaphone so that if we were call at
least we wouldn't be accused of spying
uh I wouldn't find the equipment
and we waited and then nothing happened
uh for at least a couple of hours
so and by this time it was getting dark
so we decided that we would um we'll go
to the next Village
where we which was about three
kilometers away so we we broke cover and
walking down the road and every time a
vehicle come we would dive in the in the
ditch in the drainage ditches by the
side of the road
um and we managed to get to a little
village
what we then did was we were and of
course the village in total darkness so
we found a gastata or a local German Pub
as it was then had to sign up knocked on
the door and uh in true sort of fashion
a little a little slide kind of you know
undid and looked at us and we told him
in German that we were military liaison
officers and that could we use their
phone anyway the door opened and and we
went in and um and lo and behold it was
what you and I would equate to a lock-in
right so the place the pub was full uh
in total darkness on the outside so we
went in walked through the people and he
showed us where the phone was and anyway
we made a call often he offered us a
drink so we had a had a quick beer with
him uh while we made a phone call to the
British Embassy in Berlin
and um and so knowing that that actually
collaborating or helping military
missions was again a punishable offense
under the starsy rules we decided that
we would leave the pub and and because
we didn't want to get in any trouble
what we found that and we went and hid
in a bus shelter
um after we'd made the call because we
knew that British Embassy would contact
Rick smiths in Berlin
and about 30 minutes after we were in
the bus shelter suddenly there was a
hive of activity of starsy vehicles come
in the village which immediately told us
that the British embassy's phones were
tapped oh right yeah which of course we
knew that but this was confirmation that
you know because we'd phoned from this
phone number
um and anyway so we were out and out
behind the lines for about 12 hours
before our uh another vehicle came from
Potsdam because it was a couple of hours
drive to pick us up
hmm God sounds pretty intense
it had its moment it had its moments I
mean it's interesting because listening
to your talk about this which happened a
long time ago there's definitely
parallels between what's happening now
and you know when you look at what's
going on now in Russia do you see
Putin's actions as part of an attempt to
reclaim the Soviet Union yeah I think I
think um I think he always you know
after parastrika after reunification uh
under under Gorbachev I think it was
um happened
I think although Putin was part of the
of the team that that sort of created
and pushed forward I don't think they
thought that the Soviet Union would
break apart so quickly as it did
um and so I think from that moment on
he has always wanted uh reunification of
of the Soviet Union and in particular
um the satellite countries to produce if
you like a a Country-Wide barrier
between Russia and the west and again I
think and I used to have some sympathy
in that direction because if I remember
rightly the only times that Russia has
really been seriously invaded has always
been from the west and so the idea that
they would have some buffer countries
that that anybody invading would have to
come through I think you know sort of in
a in a funny sense made sense however of
course
um it didn't happen the Soviet Union
broke up and all of those countries you
know Lithuania Romania Albania and all
of those former satellite countries are
now independent of their own
um and and again I think as part of his
Reclamation or formation of the of the
uh old Soviet Union he's focused on
Ukraine
um
and and I think if he succeeds in
Ukraine I think it's absolutely true he
will be emboldened by that and he will
then you know it will just be a matter
of time that other countries uh he tries
to subversify them into into getting
back the old the old Soviet Union I
think his miscalculation is just how how
good the ukrainians have been at
defending their Nation you know it's
always the old saying isn't it you know
people are always going to fight hardest
if they're defending their their country
and again what we know so far from
intelligence reports is that half the
Soviet soldiers or Russian soldiers that
are in Ukraine now don't know where they
are
um and so that for me was very
reflective of how how it was and the
tactics they're using were exactly the
same tactics that I witnessed for three
years in the 80s
and so I think you know just just using
those old tactics has been part of their
undoing and doing everything by numbers
again huge convoys of vehicles you know
no maps and they're just being pointed
in which direction to go and of course
has made them sitting targets for for
the ukrainians
interesting really interesting take on
it and do you with someone with your
level of knowledge of that kind of you
know your experience of the Soviets back
then and you are still involved in that
kind of area now do you see any kind of
resolution to the war in the Ukraine no
I not not in not in the short term I
think um you know the Russian tactics
are exactly as they as they were then
and they are now and they have been it
when they were operating in Syria uh
under under the guise of the Syrian Army
you know it's surround bombard flatten
and then just take it
um I think and I heard somebody say this
the other day
and I agree with them I don't think that
the Russians are interested in the
people of Ukraine they just want to
occupy the territory and so I think this
isn't going to end anytime soon and um
and I hope that the West keeps
supporting them the way they do and that
we don't we don't lose interest
okay Dave look um it's a second how
we've met it was just as interesting and
fascinating this time as a first really
appreciated time and thank you for
coming in no thanks for inviting me it's
been great to meet you again
thanks thank you very much cheers
child abduction
manual which is very very detailed and
very good because they've got 10 times
as many child abductions and strange
child abductions that we've had in the
UK
um that she would have been dead within
72 hours yeah oh God
awful